Speaker 1: There's a new report out which finds
that young women are trending liberal and that
young men are not trending more liberal. The Hill
has a piece. 44% of young women counted themselves
liberal in 2021, compared to 25% of young men,
according to Gallup. The gender gap is the largest
recorded in 24 years of polling. The finding
culminates years of rising liberalism among
women ages 18 to 29, with no increase in their
male peers. The article notes, quote, Several
societal forces have conspired to push young
women to the left, including the MeToo movement,
former President Trump, rising LGBTQ ID and most
recently, abortion policy. Slow cooking trends in
marital status and educational attainment have
also nudged the needle. There is another aspect
to this. All of that is true. There is a ton
of nonsense about masculinity out there that I
believe is impacting the number of men willing
to say that they are on the left now. I think
some of them are on the left but are unwilling
to say it, but that's difficult to actually
prove. So we can even keep it outside of this
discussion. That's just an opinion that I hold,
and it's based merely on anecdotes. I think
there are some much like for a time when,
you know, a lot of times you hear there's more
gay people now than ever. Well, are there more
gay people or is it that gay folks on average are
more open to saying that that's how they identify,
whereas in the past they were not for different
societal pressures? I think right now there
is a societal. Particularly among, without a
doubt, the right wing and even among the center,
where men have been convinced that there is
a lack of masculinity in progressive beliefs,
that there is a lack of masculinity in, to
some degree, empathy. You look at you look
at silly little things like the electric vehicle
thing. We recently talked about Marjorie Taylor
GREENE suggesting that Pete booted judge's
support of electric vehicles is somehow
feminine, that that it's emasculating to
for a man to drive an electric vehicle. And,
of course, there it was a homophobic boot.
A judge is gay, and it was all mixed up
with this homophobia. That is just a big
thing for Marjorie Taylor GREENE. You know
think also people to judge being uninvolved.
Dad when Pete booted judge and his husband
had twins, Pete booted judge took paternity leave
and he was widely ridiculed by the right. Lauren
Boebert even saying, what is he chest feeling?
That's a quote. Is he chest feeding? And again,
the idea that gay man paternity leave, well,
it must be somehow feminine. Well, he's just
being a good dad. That's all it is. And so I
believe that that's a factor as well. And sadly,
some of these sort of guru type figures that are
predominantly appealing to those on the right.
Um, although Jordan Peterson
appeals to many on the left as well,
I'll be totally upfront about that. Although
it may not be explicit from Jordan Peterson,
he puts together a pretty clearly defined kind
of archetype for masculinity. That doesn't really
include the types of empathetic, sensitive,
progressive beliefs and perspectives that,
quite frankly, have nothing to do with
masculinity. So I think there's a lot
going on here, and it is not surprising that
we see in terms of overt identification,
young women identifying more to the left, but
not young men. Now, then there's that other X
factor. And it's are some of these young men
actually progressive? But they don't say it
because of that very same societal pressure. And
I don't know the answer to that. Someone who knows
more about research methods might be able to say,
Well, here's how you could study where there is
a sort of reticent progressivism among some young
men. Let me know your thoughts. I don't think this
is particularly good. If I'm passing some kind
of a moral evaluation of it, I don't think it's
a particularly good thing for society. Let me know
your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And if we get some interesting feedback, we'll do
a follow up. The David Pakman Show is, of course,
a viewer and listener funded program.
We do the bonus show every single day.
We have a commercial free audio and video
stream of the show for our members, and the
way you get it all, get it all and get it quickly
and cheaply. Just the way people love. By signing
up at join Packman dot com, you can use the coupon
code abominable 0bam and a that's Mike Nancy and a
to get a sizable discount a discount nobody should
sneeze at join Packman dot com is the place.